brent how are you hey i'm great how are
you i'm doing fantastic let's just jump
right into uh the difference between
being a hedge against inflation versus a
hedge against loose monetary policy
forget bitcoin for a second like what's
the difference in those two things
because it's somewhat nuanced but
important
sure so really the difference is that
policy reacts to inflation so if you're
trying to find things that are
hedging against inflation you need
things that aren't going to be crushed
by policy so
risky assets generally get crushed when
policy reacts to inflation
whereas certain other things
like commodities and bonds
10 or short you have to be short bonds
of course as an inflation hedge
tend to
work even when policy reacts so
what you get essentially is two waves
you get the loose policy which is what
we had extremely loose policy uh fiscal
and monetary
and that drives the price of all assets
up but the highest beta or the the most
volatile assets
are the most risky assets so
you know ethereum bitcoin um and then
after that you had like nasdaq stocks
meme stocks uh all that kind of stuff um
reacts the most to loose monetary policy
and there's a whole bunch of
vectors for transmission i mean one of
them is just sentiment
um there's you kind of get this panic to
the top side essentially but then what
happens is eventually the policymakers
have to react to the inflation and
tighten monetary policy
so then that's when the rubber hits the
road on on whether something's an
inflation hedge or not so things like
commodities or short bonds have
continued to perform well as the fed is
tightened
whereas obviously bitcoin and and more
speculative assets have performed poorly
so what i'm talking about here is a
cyclical thing
and then um what a lot of people believe
is a more structural thing which is that
loose monetary policy which you i would
just say mmt is kind of like the basic
framework which is
uh very loose fiscal
and it's kind of um
aided and abetted by monetary so
that's kind of like the primary
framework like the old keynesian thing
where you you stimulate when things are
bad and then you pull back fiscal when
things are good that's kind of gone in
the garbage and now it's a lot more like
about mmt so that started with like the
tcga which was trump's tax cut um in the
in the at the peak which is extremely
unusual totally unheard of um and
continued with the coveted response
so i think there's also this structural
element of you know these things like
bitcoin as as a hedge
will work in the long run because
money is being debased you know in but
then that's a structural thing and then
you got to watch out for the cycles
which obviously the cycles can be nasty
and
um i'm not saying this in hindsight so
like i was writing about this in
november of 2021
that like the party's pretty much over
as you know the inflation and
like loose policy and raging inflation
is like mana for risky assets and for
for things like bitcoin and but then
when eventually policy reacts with a lag
then you gotta watch out
so i think the some i mean some people
would i know someone responded on
twitter yeah like thanks for the update
obviously this is like i can see the
prices on the screen
um and i mean that's certainly fair to
some extent but i don't think it's
totally fair because lots of people were
making this observation including me um
in november so
it's not it's not all hindsight and also
i do think there's an importance or a
usefulness to understanding
the current cycle so that the next cycle
you understand it better
julie no i was going to say like where
where do you think we're headed from
here because as you pointed out this is
something you were writing about back in
november where are we headed
so
i'm like very cautiously
optimistic now like i'm a little bit
more bullish crypto but definitely not
raging bullish
there's a few things so one is that the
terminal rate which is like how high is
the fed gonna go
is pretty high now in terms of what the
market expects so
the room for rates to go higher to me is
pretty limited
unless you got like another full-on
subsequent inflation shock which i don't
think we'll get which would mean like
probably that would mean oil to 150 or
something like that which is not my base
case so i'm consciously optimistic
because i think we're kind of around
peak
fed
but then you know just the way i was
saying you got to separate the cyclical
from the structural you also have to
separate
the endogenous from the exogenous so
crypto has been getting hit by exogenous
which is external forces which is macro
higher real rates tightening policy
essentially like the inverse of the fiat
d basement trade right so
people correctly saw crypto and
specifically bitcoin as a fiat
debasement hedge and that was true but
then if the fed hikes real rates from
minus one to plus one you know fiat
debasement isn't really a thing as much
anymore because
fiat currency has positive um you know
positive value in theory um
so
the question now is
okay if that exogenous shock is done
which i kind of think it is like i think
the fed's close to probably peak
although i will just say one quick
little caveat there
is that the fed tends to always fight
the last war so that's what you got with
flexible average inflation targeting
was they failed to to get inflation up
for so long that they finally like said
okay screw it we're all in
and of course that was the worst
possible timing
so now they're going to be fighting the
last war again which is they're going to
be scared of inflation the politics of
inflation are bad it makes the fed look
bad they're hurting credibility wise so
i don't think it's going to be like 2018
2019 where they just went from like
hiking to cutting
my feeling is probably they just stay on
hold for ages once they find their happy
place
um so that's the exogenous story which
is like getting better but it's not
amazing but then you have this
endogenous which is like the internal
factors of crypto
which i think is like
maybe reaching a crescendo around now um
and it comes down to liquidations right
like 3ac and and all that stuff
um so like i've been dabbling for
example in gbtc
because like the biggest holder of gbtc
is is 3ac and
so i'm guessing there's going to be some
force liquidation there and that's part
of probably why
the discount has widened so far
so i believe in the structural crypto
story as i think
mmt and my completely insane
fiscal and monetary policy in tandem
is like the base case for the next 20
years
but then i am more of a trader so i tend
to like ride the cycles as well
and so i feel like if you're riding the
cycle from the short side like short
aetherium or whatever that trade's over
and now it's more like i don't think
it's the raging bull scenario either i
think it's more like you dabble you pick
your spots
and
you know if you're an investor
or you're looking for like long-term
debasement uh insurance in your
portfolio you know buying bitcoin from
here down to 10k makes a ton of sense to
me
and honestly like i don't know if you
want to go into it but to me most almost
every other like
altcoin and i would include ethereum
obviously not as an altcoin but i would
include ethereum as
i feel like those are just a completely
different category and
they might not work as as fiat
debasement hedges they might just all go
to zero
all right i'll take the next one then um
you mentioned
kind of going down to 10k like is that
where you're kind of expecting a bottom
like what's kind of your outlook um for
bitcoin and maybe if you have like a
time horizon on that
sure so i i think this is a boring view
but i mean sometimes views are boring um
and my is that we just chop um and so
chop into probably like into q1 of next
year
and then i think that's the point where
you'll probably get more visibility on
fed policy being uh you know the fed
being done hiking um you're also gonna
eventually get into the better part of
the having cycle which is which will be
helpful
um and then in terms of where we bought
them i mean the tech levels were pretty
good on the way up and they haven't been
very good on the way down
and the reason i think for that is that
texts are a lot of behavior
there's a lot of behavioral element to
technical analysis
so when it's like a behavioral story on
the way up the levels kind of like the
levels like 69k obviously being the
ultimate meme level
uh work but on the way down there's a
lot more for selling and liquidation
and for selling and liquidation doesn't
care about technicals so
if you're looking for levels like 20
obviously was was that huge breakout um
in whenever that was i guess late 2020
um and we briefly went below that on the
weekend um
down to 17.5 the other level so by
basically buying between 20 and 10 i
mean i know that's a super wide window
but
if you're buying for like longer term
insurance i think that's the window to
buy
the reason i'm looking at like down to
10 is 11 4 is 85 off the highs
and so the in first crypto winter we
were 84 off the highs
and there's a weird um
commonness i don't know that's a word
but commonness to 85 drawdowns in
um super speculative assets like if you
go through the list of like what are the
big bubbles in the last like 25 years
um so crypto in 2017 obviously was one
nasdaq 2000
um housing in 2006
all of those things uh nikkei in 1990
all of those things
went high to low 85 percent um
so
85 percent is 11.4 in bitcoin so i feel
like that's like a reasonable place to
to kind of
think that i i mean i don't think it
goes that far down to be honest but that
would be like worst case scenario right
um you mentioned uh liquidation i
suppose that's probably a risk that
you're paying attention to how do you
begin to you know assess that risk um
how widespread do you think that might
be
so i i actually wrote a piece about this
so i have a lot of experience in in
tradify with liquidations going all the
way back to like bear stearns
liquidating
through jp jp was liquidating in this
huge position in march 20 and 2008 and i
remember that well because i was trading
i actually worked at lehman brothers at
that time
and so the thing about liquidations is
there's two things one they don't care
what the price is right they're just
they sell because they have to sell
and generally it's not like an
optimization exercise it's just like a
risk reduction exercise
the other thing is that you tend to see
it cluster around the turns of the
months the quarters and the half year
end so this is a particularly
interesting little period right here
that we're in
because a lot of the gates um so you see
the same thing with inflows actually
like
during the good times bitcoin and crypto
tends to perform very well at the turn
of the month and part of the reason is
that that's when people get paid so
retail puts money in but then the other
reason is that that's when inflows
happen so most hedge funds and
institutions the gates and the entry
points and the exit points tend to be
around the turns of the round um
points on the calendar so this is a
really interesting time right now i
think that um
if you can kind of like survive this
this next like i don't know let's say
five days i think actually that's like
peak
peak liquidation window for the next
little while and we and we could
stabilize and at least then
so like obviously there's the
correlation to nasdaq and and all that
which i kind of believe is a somewhat
permanent feature of of crypto um
although not completely like you know
the correlations are are not static but
they can still also be kind of
structural and persistent over time um
so i think that correlation will be
somewhat structural and persistent but
at the same time
at least the endogenous aspect of like
just liquidation i think is actually
probably going to draw to a close in the
next week or so
and then um you know things might
actually calm down so i'm a little bit a
little bit more optimistic going into
july specifically as more of like a
tactical play
to be long um into july but scaling in
between now and like fourth of july
because
of liquidation risk and then also the
holiday and the weekend and all that so
brent that's was my question was around
uh there's a couple of things that are
going to happen over the next five days
and you mentioned that bitcoin must
survive over the next five days uh and i
think that you're talking less about
bitcoin going to zero as much as just
kind of chopping sideways here uh we
have the end of the
first half of the year the end of the
second quarter there's all sorts of
redemptions and things that go on with
funds and and maybe some force selling
there you have the liquidation risk uh
throughout the industry we've seen a big
washout of a lot of liquidation but
doesn't mean it's over uh you've got the
um grayscale bitcoin trust decision
coming up from the sec in july there
could be some movement around that but
there's also kind of a positive story
around the retail inflows because people
get paid either at the end or beginning
of a month uh there's also people
putting new capital into whether it's
hedge funds or other types of funds that
will go buy these assets uh and then i
think the one piece we've seen arthur
hayes write a whole piece uh calling out
uh the july fourth holiday having this
kind of illiquidity uh where people
can't take fiat from their bank account
and put it into their crypto account to
go and purchase assets uh if they do
drop we saw when bitcoin went down to 17
500 uh two or three weeks ago it was
over a three day weekend there was a
banking holiday that weekend how do you
kind of put together this confluence of
events that's about to occur uh between
end of q2 beginning of a new month
you've got the banking holiday like just
talk through how you kind of evaluate
what you expect to happen over the next
five days sure i mean i think you've
covered it pretty much perfectly there
so essentially what you're describing is
downside risk until fourth or fifth of
july and then probably it's safer to be
bullish so when i was saying if you
survive i i was talking about trading
from the long side you know people that
use that are using stop losses um
certainly bitcoin will survive the next
seven days um god willing um so i would
so the way that i handle this is to
scale in so
i don't think you want to try to like
pin the tail on the donkey and pick like
the perfect entry point so i just want
to separate two things so i'm up till
this point i've mostly been talking
about um structural more like investor
mentality um now i'm talking more trader
mentality which is actually more what i
do um is much more
you know like in for three weeks or
three months kind of stuff that's
generally what i do both in crypto and
in um fiat
or tradify
so the way that i would handle it is
that you you think there's going to be
downside pressure or risk of downside
pressure over the next say say ten seven
days so you split up your purchases over
seven days
and then once you're in you pick a stop
loss probably like my stop loss would be
below the lows at like sixteen nine or
something like that
and then you try to ride the rebound
which i do think july actually i'm
pretty optimistic like i said for the
month of july once we get through this
window
now the one thing
like if you want to play the second
derivative game or like the the
third derivative game if arthur hayes is
talking about it and i'm talking about
it obviously other people are talking
about it too
and that's also part of why i want to
scale in and not just wait for the end
um like you might think that the optimal
strategy would just be like by at 4 pm
on july 4th once all this you know once
the hurricane has passed but the problem
is everyone knows about this so
the risk is actually that that it's
wrong that that analysis is wrong and
you miss the whole thing and we're at 23
8 on july 5th and you're like oh shoot i
missed it so in order to avoid missing
it that's what i'm doing is just going
like you know split it into five
purchases of 20 each and then once i
have my average i'll put my stop below
the lows julia what else you got
i would just love to hear more about um
maybe more of like your macro views as
it relates to
policy like
do you think like mmt is that going to
be here to stay
i would say 100 so
i mean to me like i've studied the red
stephanie kelton stuff and all that to
me it's like a completely insane policy
that has no limiting factor it basically
has no breaks so even if like stephanie
kelton is the expert on this and even
when i hear her responses to like what's
the limiting factor
i just don't find it convincing like to
think that politicians are going to
raise taxes or that government's going
to correctly target spending or withdraw
spending to me it's just like there's no
way that's ever going to work so
if you believe that uh which i do and
then it's the oh and you also believe so
the
whole thing of how spending in
government and keynesian policy and
economics basically worked for my entire
lifetime and probably the 50 years
before that was that there's a
connection between revenue and spending
and the connection's loose and you can
argue about it and you can say like how
are we going to spend spent how are we
going to pay for it when new spending is
announced but there was always the
question of like how are we going to pay
for it even if they were bullshitting
and and really they weren't paying for
it there was that connection between tax
taxation and spending now that has been
snipped there's no anchor whatsoever for
spending um they don't even ask the
question anymore they just spend and
don't like it doesn't even matter where
the money's coming from
um so that that ship having sailed as a
politician it's just always easier to
spend more
and in the past the limiting factor was
kind of like this
taboo on
on spending during good times there was
kind of like this taboo deficits tended
to increase in bad times and then you
you know clinton had a surplus in the
good times so that whole thing is gone
and i just i don't see it coming back
and the only thing that would break it
would be some kind of like
extremely disorderly
um inflation
that creates this sort of volcker moment
where
the the politics of spending completely
change and i just even with this
inflation even with inflation at eight
or ten percent i don't think we're even
close to that moment so if that moment's
gonna happen probably not even next
cycle it's probably like the next cycle
after that so
that you know if these cycles are say
two to five years
going to change on this front for at
least 10 years it would be like i mean
that's my guess um and that's a lot of
runway for for something like bitcoin to
appreciate in the long run so brent when
you start to think about uh bitcoin over
let's call it the next couple of years
uh is the macro uh kind of story just uh
you're hedging against mmt you're
hedging against a continuation of the
fiscal policies almost more so than the
monetary policies or how do you balance
kind of monetary and fiscal policies uh
in relationship to bitcoin over the
coming years
well i think you need both turned on in
order for the trade to really work like
that obviously the empirical evidence
suggests that but i think logically as
well
you know what it what you're looking for
is deep debasement of the currency and
that really is fiscal spending that's um
monetized or you know aided and abetted
by monetary policy so if they're pushing
in opposite directions like that's not
really that's not really the
prescription for extreme debasement the
debasement prescription is spending
money and printing it to cover it and
like there's a whole debate just
so people don't at me there's a whole
debate about whether it's printing money
or whatever but
increasing m2 or increasing the monetary
base
to me is essentially the denominator in
the in the fraction and
you know if the denominator keeps on
getting bigger
um
then then there's going to be a reaction
in assets and to me like the you can
argue that there's definitely an
argument to be made through my framework
that something like nasdaq is like or
levered nasdaq would be similar
and i agree somewhat but there's there's
a lot more stuff and
going on with nasdaq in terms of like
you got to worry about earnings and all
that to me bitcoin is just a lot simpler
in terms of
it has one thing that it's doing in my
mind and it's good at that thing and so
like i don't want to screw around and
worry about whether apple's buying back
stock or not buying back stock and
whether iphones you know are going to
get
beaten up by some other competitor and
all that
and whether the mega caps are
overweighted in the index and all that i
just feel like
even if you can argue that there are a
lot of similarities in terms of the
purpose of these of some of the assets
other than bitcoin i just feel like
bitcoin does the job better
what do you think um
i mean it's just like when you when you
i just want to go back to mmt for a sec
because like when you talk about that
and what the consequences could be and
like what it might mean for the
appreciation of bitcoin like
i mean nobody has like a crystal bond
could like imagine what the future looks
like but when you start to
parse out that scenario or think about
like what do you think it means even for
like the younger generations you know
who might be watching this program like
what are the longer term consequences
i mean i think everything that's going
on right now is just
is the p is the the petri dish or
whatever you want to call it right we're
seeing it we're seeing the result of the
experiment in real time the result is
hard assets go up a lot
um and there's a lot of pain and in
there's a lot of income inequality
and i just don't see that changing i
feel like the framework that the
orthodox policy makers are using is the
same everywhere
and like if you know if i i would say
like i'd be hopeful because i i think
this policy is bad um because of income
inequality and inflation and all that
but so if if i were to be hopeful i
would see at least some smaller
economies like say new zealand or canada
or some of the smaller economies that
have tended to be leaders um in terms of
monetary policy
until like the intellectual leaders in
monetary policy have tended to be the
smaller countries like new zealand and
they're not they're not pivoting at all
either so
i don't see a lot of evidence or hope
that that this stuff is going to change
and the ramifications are really i mean
not
to have to oversimplify it but just look
around whatever's happening right now
that's that's what's going to keep on
happening and it's probably going to get
worse
and
what it essentially means is that we
continue with these cycles of
you know explosive monetary growth that
leads to a lot of inflation and then
like oh [ __ ] moments where the central
banks try to get the horse back in the
barn for a while but they don't have the
political will
to to withstand unemployment once it
starts going up so
then you know the whole cycle begins
again
now obviously like covid was a crazy
super turbo example of of this policy so
i don't think the next recession is
going to see anything like what we just
saw
um it'll be just this series of of many
um qes or mini mini mmt or mmt lite
compared to what we just saw which was
like mmt on steroids because of the
crisis
so brent when you start to think about
uh the fed obviously they continue to
remain committed to increasing interest
rates uh at least through the end of the
year they're talking about 50 75 basis
point hikes uh they're doing it though
with q1 gdp contracting we don't know
what'll happen in q2 yet what's your
thought process in terms of uh when will
they kind of wave the white flag and
give up is there one or two milestones
that you're looking at saying you know
this is the moment that either something
breaks or something gets to the point
where they have to give up and they'll
return back to lose monetary policy
so
there's there's two things so like
there's one when can they when will they
stop tightening and then the next one is
when do they go back to loosening
um when they stop tightening i think
first of all they just need to get to
neutral so i think that has been the
message is that they're so far behind
the curve
that they first just have to get to
neutral so wherever that is let's say
around three percent or something
um and then they'll probably pause and
then it will come down to the data so
part of the reason that i don't think
long-term rates can go up much more from
here is that i i agree with you they're
hiking into weakness because one
built-in flaw of
monetary policy as as it operates now
is that it eases very quickly
like in a panic in any emergency
and then it tightens extremely slowly so
by the time they're tightening they're
tightening into weakness because they
waited so long i mean they were still
buying assets in february when inflation
was at seven percent so
that just shows like how lagged their
policy is so i think that they
if they're what they've kind of done now
is like specifically said we're watching
cpi and cpi is a super lagged indicator
so you know you can look around and see
commodity prices are down 20 25 housing
looks like it's peaked trucking autos
like everything's all prices of
everything are falling but the problem
is cpi's lag cpi lags so i think they're
just going to keep tightening into
economic weakness
and the thing is it's not just the us
right like europe and everywhere else is
is pretty weak as well
so i think they're going to keep
tightening into weakness and then
they'll get to neutral they'll stop and
the economy will probably be weak enough
by that point which would be like kind
of q1 2023 the economy would be weak
enough at that point that they probably
should be cutting but i think they'll be
scared to cut because they got scarred
but like i said like i was saying like
the fighting the last war thing so i
think they'll be actually kind of slow
to cut in 2023 but that's the path in
2023. so brent one of our sponsors is
eight sleep and i spent a lot of time
thinking about uh just how do you
optimize your life outside of uh just
staring at screens all day long
and uh eight hours of sleep is a huge
piece for me how do you think about in
these bear markets where uh people seem
to you can feel the sentiment on twitter
people are much more uh worked up
they're much more stressed out you you
feel people just almost like attacking
each other more
and there's liquidations there's kind of
these sudden abrupt moves some that also
violate what people thought was going to
happen previously what do you do in your
own life to kind of keep a clear head
and just make sure that you can kind of
get through this without going nuts or
you know freaking out and having a rage
quit on twitter or something like that
sure so yeah i've written quite a bit
about this because
i feel like part of my reason that i've
survived so long in finance is like that
i've looked at some of these issues and
taken them seriously um so for example i
turn my phone off at 10 and i turn it on
when i wake up
um whereas say like eight years ago
if i got up to go to the bathroom i'd
check my phone where's dolly yan where's
the euro where's smps
and that just like has absolutely no
value it doesn't have any financial
value because if you make a trading
decision if i make a trading decision at
that time it's generally a bad one with
incomplete information would land no
edge
um and then it kind of like makes your
next day worse because you haven't slept
as well so that's one simple thing is
like create friction around unwanted
behaviors so like my unwanted behavior
was checking my phone at night so now i
turn it off and i put it downstairs so
like i'm not there's no chance i'm
stumbling downstairs in the pitch black
to check my phone you know to see where
s ps are at 3 15 in the morning
um
and then sort of on that same topic of
of either creating friction around
unwanted behaviors or
automating good behaviors um i always
automate all my orders so i always put
stops and take profits on every single
position that i have
and i feel like that kind of means that
you don't need to be staring at the
screen all day like
there isn't a ton of value like i
actually closed my trading platform half
the time um i mean generally because of
my job i know where markets are roughly
but i would say
all the trading that i do i try to have
my plan when i put it on
and then i just put my orders in and you
know inshallah i kind of wait for it to
happen and i don't think like the some
people will say well there's there's
value in watching the price action i i
just don't really believe that i don't
think price action contains a lot of
information
other than around major events you know
the way that things trade like good news
bad price and things like that i think
have value but generally i think you
have to
look at your behaviors and say like is
this adding to my overall utility or no
and be thoughtful about it and say okay
this is stupid there's no reason to
check my phone in the middle of the
night for example so i'm going to x that
that that activity and i think you can
go through a lot of things and and do
that
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or subscribe to all your
writing
so spectra markets.com is where
everything is so i write a daily global
macro um which is like kind of my main
thing
and then i write a weekly crypto piece
as well
um which is more through the lens of
like
macro behavioral technical um that kind
of lens like i don't get into like l1
versus l2 solutions and stuff like that
that's not my my thing i'm more like a
macro macro guys so yep spectra
markets.com all right my actually i live
my last question says that you like
table tennis are you good
i'm pretty good yeah i would say like
i'm not professional but if you just put
me against like random person
i think like 99 of normal people i could
beat but not ever like no i mean not an
olympic
tennis table tennis player
there's three there's three categories
of 10 uh table tennis players there's
people who just volley there's people
who can put what i call amateur spin on
the ball and then there's the pros and
it sounds like you're in that second
bucket which means that you would beat
99 of people listening or watching this
yeah i mean like talk to your second
bucket but nowhere near the third bucket
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for uh for joining us we'll
definitely have to do this again awesome
thanks for having me hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time